kevin starts this hour off in birmingham
alabama hi kevin welcome to the dave
ramsey show
good evening dave how are you better
than i deserve what's up in your world
well got a quick question me and my wife
just moved back home to alabama
um she is now a stay-at-home mom or with
our brand new four-month-old
congratulations thank you sir
well yeah uh i have a i brought a lot of
stupidity into our marriage
that she's helping me clean up we have
about eighteen
thousand dollars in active debt which is
just a personal loan and student loans
uh we have about three thousand dollars
that's actually in collections
her vehicle is paid for and i have a
truck that's got about 3 500
negative equity for me to spell it to
get out from another loan
um my question is we we actually we sold
our house
in florida from where we moved to and
we've got a
24 000 hammer to start
i just don't know should i just go ahead
and clear out all the debt
and then work on my truck or should i
get rid of my truck first
because i have a 600 payment that's just
hurting us each month yeah so what's the
truck worth
uh the truck is worth 31 000
uh on private retail yeah and i owe
right at 34
five yeah payoff gotcha okay and what's
your household income
uh it's just me right now and it's right
at sixty one thousand a year
i bring home roughly 4 500 a month
okay so um my opinion if you listen to
me for more
30 seconds you probably know this is
that you have too much truck even if it
were paid for
yeah because you don't want more than
half your annual income tied up with
things with wheels and motors
and your truck alone violates that so um
even if it were paid for i'd be looking
at you got too much truck so
yeah truck's gone and we've got to
replace it and we got to cover the 3 500
so what are you going to spend on what
you're going to drive
for the next year and a half or two
years while you get out of debt you're
not going to drive it forever but what
are you going to spend on that
get out of debt car or truck uh
the ones i've been looking at are right
around fifteen hundred to two thousand
dollars because my wife's vehicle is
very dependable
and it's paid for okay and i'm just i'm
looking at a fifteen hundred dollar
beater to get to and from work i just
drive a bit of assistance but yeah i
i would i would kick that up to five
thousand in your situation that's not
going to keep you from hitting your
goals
and so we need five thousand dollars for
that we need thirty five hundred dollars
for the hole that you're in
right yes sir so we just spent the first
eighty
three hundred and five hundred eighty
three hundred dollars or so right
yes sir okay and uh then we've got
twenty
five thousand dollar hammer twenty four
thousand dollar hammer twenty two
thousand what was the size again
it's uh it's gonna be right it's twenty
four thousand dollars is how much money
we have right now okay
the stuff that you have in collections
is it are you paying payments on it
actively
no sir okay are they hounding you
yes uh i've tried to settle with them um
before
and it's it just went into a collection
status
and they're not i tried the whole you
know way towards the end of the month
and kind of hammered them and they it
doesn't work
yeah i mean end of the month helps some
but that's just because they're trying
to hit their personal goals on
collections
you're just trying to help the idiot in
the cube that's doing the collections
so it doesn't really help the company
the company doesn't give a rip
but they're just trying to hit quotas uh
because it's a phone room is what a
collections operation is
you know and they're all sitting there
with bonuses and spiffs and whatever so
that's the only that's the only thing
you got working on your favorite so yeah
they're just not ripe yet let them sit
there
uh and then let's just start working the
debt snowball with the rest of it listed
smallest to largest
but basically we've got the money to get
rid of the truck and replace the truck
with a five thousand dollar
uh get around car okay yes sir so set
aside nine thousand dollars
you know give yourself a little wiggle
room that's over here this is the truck
exit fund and then the rest of it we're
gonna work that at snowball with
collections is just not getting anything
because
they're not softened up yet when they
get softened up we'll write them a check
yes sir should i should i be sitting
should i set aside any money
uh you know which i've read the steps to
put a thousand dollars up and then use
the rest on debt
should i put some kind of to the spot
for
the collections when they come or just
yeah
yeah if you're out of money when they
get there you just go well you guys
missed your shot i told you
i'll get to you when i get to you now
now you're you're sidelined by your own
idiocy
okay so so knock out the truck first get
that out of our life and then work on
the debt
no it's all it's a not and then it's at
the same time we just set 9000 aside it
takes a little while to get the truck
sold
got to get it sold then you got to buy
another one meanwhile you're going to
take the rest of that money and work
your debt snowball
okay that's that's that's where i was
kind of confused get uh
because the truck's killing us though
it's got to go yeah it does it's just
too much
and especially situation you're in today
and the the bad news is you guys are
going through all this the good news is
with a brand new baby and a bright
future
you got a lot of reasons to clean this
up so you're the kind of guy that will
clean it up you're not gonna
go like when i needed you stopping going
vacation because i'm a wuss
no you're going to go through and clean
it up
you're the dude man i'm proud of you get
after it i love it
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five so for those of you that have not
tuned in here very often or
don't know these details these folks
always throw these baby steps around
like there's some kind of gospel or
something they're not
they're just the most proven effective
way
to get out of debt and build wealth
and become outrageously generous
and this is the goal with money there's
lots of other good goals in life to have
but with money
when we get out of debt we have money
and the first three baby steps are done
with what we call gazelle
intensity which means you are running
hard and doing nothing but thinking
about staying alive like a gazelle
running from a cheetah
and you aren't and so when you're in
when you're broke and in debt
like that guy was you're not going out
to eat
you're broken in debt you have a 35
000 truck with a 600 car payment
your butt does not need to see the
inside of a restaurant unless you're
working there as an extra job
you're on beans and rice rice and beans
cleaning up the freaking mess you made
when you were a child now that you are
growing up
i'm not punishing you i'm telling you
this is the fastest way out
and people that ying and you can play
with this stuff
the cheetah eats their butt you don't
see gazelles kind of go like i think
i'll run a little no
they run for their freaking lives
it's not a game and they're not going on
vacation
they're using every dollar they can find
they're working extra you're selling so
much stuff the kids think they're next
we're cleaning up this mess
and that's baby steps one get a thousand
dollars two get out of debt using the
debt snowball everything but your house
and three is your emergency fund most
people are doing that
in one two maybe three years with
gazelle intensity then you lighten up a
little bit and you start your building
wealth plan
but when you're in the middle of the
mess you got no money and you're in debt
you can't afford to go out to eat you're
a broke person